[Music]
if this is your first night at fight
club
you have to fight
hello everyone and welcome to a new
episode of rt essentials i'm mark ellis
hollywood has proven that it's capable
of adapting pretty much anything into a
movie these days comic books podcasts
poems video games you get it but it
pretty much all started with adapting
one thing in particular books book
adaptations are responsible for some of
the most popular influential and
transformative films of all time sure
not every great book makes a great movie
but a lot of times it does especially
with the right director writer and
actors behind it so let's break down 10
of those films that came from popular
books and went on to become important
clicks in their own right this is our
list of the best book adaptations ever
so put down your reading glasses and
pick up your um
i don't know watching video glasses and
let's do this thing
a clockwork orange
that says
this is
i see that it's wrong
it's wrong because it's like against
society
it's wrong because everybody has the
right to live and be happy without being
told tonight
no no boy you really must leave it to us
and be careful about it and it helps at
the time i mean tone will kick things
off with 1971's a clockwork orange the
film was adapted produced and directed
by stanley kubrick and is based on the
1962 novel of the same name by anthony
burgess considered to be one of the most
influential dystopian books ever
published and the story takes place in a
future britain dystopia where a gang
leader named alex played by malcolm
mcdowell is sent to prison for a murder
where he agrees to take part in a
behavioral modification experiment one
that doesn't quite go as planned the
book didn't initially capture the
interest of kubrick who was busy on
another project until his wife read it
and put it back in front of him and told
him to at least consider it
ultimately burgess sold the film rights
to his novel for 500 bucks which would
be about 5 000 today and kubrick got
right to work on a script he based it on
the us version of the book which omitted
the final chapter
this sucked
if i may call it such does not become
your my little brothers
as i am your drug and leader i'm
entitled to know what goes on eh
now then dim
what does that great big horsey gape of
a green portent
due to the film's depictions of graphic
violence the reviews at first were a bit
polarizing especially given the copycat
acts of violence were being reported and
resulting in it being pulled from
theaters in some cities even burgess
himself while calling the film brilliant
said that it might be so much so that
it's actually dangerous but a clockwork
orange ended up performing quite well at
the box office and has since undergone a
critical reevaluation in the year since
its release gaining the certified fresh
respect from critics to go along with a
huge cult following the film also
received four academy award nominations
including best picture best director and
the big one for today's list best
adapted screenplay but lost all of them
to the french connection also a book
adaptation
fight club
this is a chemical burden
you'll hurt more than you've ever been
burned and you will have a scar
guided meditation work for cancer could
work for this stay with the pain don't
shut this out
don't get your hand first soap was made
from the ashes of heroes like the first
monkey shot into space without pain
without sacrifice we would have nothing
i tried not to think the searing or
flesh
punching its way next onto this list is
1999's fight club this film is based on
chuck palahniuk's 1996 novel of the same
name and was directed by david fincher
in it edward norton stars as an
insomnia-stricken depressed man who
meets a strange soap salesman played by
brad pitt and together they start an
underground fight club for the men who
are sick of their ho-hum lives before
the book was even published it started
making its way around hollywood with a
studio reader and a couple of producers
rejecting it at first but eventually a
couple of producers saw some potential
and arranged for unpaid screen readings
of the book by actors those were trimmed
down and sent to the desk of laura
ziskin the head of fox 2000 studios at
the time she hired jim yules to write
the adaptation and brought on fincher to
direct in part because of his enthusiasm
for the story
i am jack's smirking revenge
[Music]
oh
what the hell are you doing
[Music]
when fight club hit theaters in 99 it
failed to meet the studio's expectations
had some polarizing reviews and critics
and became one of the most controversial
and talked about movies of the year the
real success came with the film's home
video release helping to create a cult
following and forcing critics and pop
culture to revisit the film ten years
later the new york times called it quote
the cult movie of our time end quote
arthur palanik was happy with the
adaptation and appreciated the
streamlining of the plot so much that he
even called the film an improvement on
his novel and speaking of palanik he
followed the book up with two sequels in
comic book form fight club 2 released in
2015 and fight club 3 in 2019 and the
fact that i'm talking about this at all
means i'm probably kicked out of fight
club
the godfather
i'm calling and give me
but you're not justice with respect
you don't offer friendship
you don't even think to call me
godfather
instead you come into my house on the
day my daughters to be married and you
ask me
agreeing to a favor and appearing next
on this list is 1972's
the godfather this epic crime drama was
directed by francis ford coppola and
based on mario puzo's best-selling 1969
novel of the same name
the film follows the corleone family
under patriarch vito corleone played by
marlon brando who was looking to pass
down control of his organized prime
dynasty to his reluctant son michael
played by a young al pacino
the book went on to be a smash hit
sitting on the new york times bestseller
list for over 67 weeks and selling over
nine million copies in two years and
paramount ended up bringing kuzo on to
help adapt it into a movie alongside
coppola the pair worked separately on
their versions of the screenplay but
remained in contact to pick and choose
what should end up in the final draft
mike
you don't come to las vegas and talk to
a man like mo green like that
fredo
you're my older brother and i love you
but don't ever take sides with anyone
against the family again
ever and it was puzzle who initially
wanted brando to play the godfather
eventually joined by coppola as they
received pushback from the studio based
on poor performances of brando's recent
films
of course he got the part and went on to
win a best actor oscar to go along with
a film winning best picture and of
course best adapted screenplay to sum it
all up perfectly the critics consensus
says that as one of hollywood's greatest
critical and commercial successes the
godfather gets everything right
the lord of the rings trilogy
sneaky little ritzy's
wicked flitzy first
no
no
master
yes precious
false
they will cheat you
hurt you
lie
next on our list of the best book
adaptations ever is not one but three
films as in the word of the rings
trilogy
this series of epic fantasy adventure
films were all directed by peter jackson
and based on j.r.r tolkien's novel of
the same name first published in 1954.
not only that but filming took place for
all three films at the same time across
new zealand in one of the most ambitious
projects ever that cost around
281 million dollars in total the story
is set in the fictional world of middle
earth with the films following a hobbit
named frodo baggins played by elijah
wood as he embarks on a quest to destroy
something called the one ring in turn
destroying its maker the dark lord
sauron
the book was actually published in three
volumes over the course of a year in
1954 and 55 for economic reasons it went
on to become one of the best selling
novels ever written with over 150
million copies sold and has been
translated into at least 38 languages
while launching a full-blown franchise
you
shall not
pass
jackson has been credited for even
attempting to adapt something as epic as
tolkien's novel and what he delivered
has been considered to be one of the
best and most influential film series
ever along with being one of the highest
grossing series of all time with nearly
3 billion dollars made worldwide
all three of the certified fresh films
the fellowship of the ring the two
towers and the return of the king have
been praised for their innovative
special effects acting music and more
and the series won 17 oscars out of 30
nominations that includes two
nominations and one win for best adapted
screenplay which came for return of the
king in 2003 as part of an 11 for 11
oscar sweep that year
wow
samson's sensibility did he tell you
that he loved you
yes
no
never absolutely
it was every day implied but never
declared
sometimes i thought it had been but it
never was
he has broken no vow
broken faith with all of us he made us
all believe he loved you and because a
list like this would be incomplete
without jane austen next up is 1995's
sense and sensibility the film is
directed by aang lee and is based on
austin's 1811 novel of the same name it
was adapted into a screenplay by emma
thompson who also stars in the film as
eleanor one of the dashwood sisters who
are forced to seek financial security
for their family through marriage after
the death of their father the novel has
been in constant publication since 1811
and has been illustrated quoted
condensed and adapted for stage movies
and television that includes twice
before this film and a 1971 tv series
and again in a 1981 series emma thompson
who was a first time screenwriter worked
on the script over the course of five
years both during and between filming
other projects and her first draft was
more than 300 handwritten pages long she
went on to earn the academy award for
best adapted screenplay for this film
becoming the first person to win oscars
for both screenwriting and acting she
won best actress for 1993's howard's end
thompson also picked up best screenplay
awards from the golden globes la film
critics association and writers guild of
america her oscar win was the only
victory out of seven nominations in
total which also included best picture
best supporting actress for kate winslet
and best actress for thompson who funny
enough was only 35 years old at the time
and only agreed to play the role of
eleanor after it was decided to change
the character's age from 19 to 27.
i've come here with no expectations
only to profess now that i am at liberty
to do so
that my heart is
and always will be
yours
[Music]
the film opened just before the holidays
in 1995 and went on to make a decent
haul at the box office and it was
credited for a resurgence in popularity
for jane austen's works and has been
continually recognized as one of the
best austin adaptations of all time and
along with that response from fans is a
critic's consensus that says sense
insensibility is an uncommonly depth
very funny jane austen adaptation marked
by emma thompson's finely tuned
performance
trainspotting
good luck spud yes cowboy now remember
what if they think you're not trying
you're in trouble right first hint of
that and they'll be on to the dhs this
is no trying and your gyro's finished
right right but then again try too
hard you might get the [ __ ] jewel
exactly nightmare it's a tightrope spud
it's a [ __ ] tightrope and after
relating to your senses and
sensibilities will appeal to something
else altogether with 1996's train
spotting this british black dramedy was
directed by danny boyle and is based on
the 1993 novel of the same name by
irvine welsh with an ensemble cast that
includes ewan mcgregor johnny lee miller
and kelly mcdonald in her acting debut
the film follows the lives of a group of
heroin addicts in a rundown part of
edinburgh scotland renton played by
mcgregor is looking to escape the scene
despite pressures from friends and the
appeal of drugs this marked the first
novel for the scottish writer welsh and
it's since developed a cult following in
its own right he followed it with a
sequel called porno in 2002 and a
prequel called skagboyz in 2012.
boyle has described welsh's book as
genuinely a masterpiece and he sealed
the deal to acquire the rights by
writing the author a kindly worded
letter if all you kids out there aren't
sure what a letter is ask your parents
it was there before yelp some people
hate english i don't they're just
wankers
we on the other hand are colonized by
wankers
can't even find a decent culture to be
colonized by
we're ruled by a fetals
it's a shocks dave affairs to being
tommy and all the fresh air in the world
won't make any difference
boyle brought on john hodge to write the
screenplay and the film ended up being a
big hit developing a cult following with
fans and being considered by critics as
one of the best films of the 1990s
trainspotting was nominated for two
bafta awards including best british film
and won one for best adapted screenplay
and award hodge was also nominated for
the academy awards but lost out to billy
bob thornton's slingblade and no i'm not
about to do my sleep great impression
you gotta pay to see that the movie was
screened out of competition at the
cannes film festival due to its subject
matter but went on to become one of the
highest grossing films of the year for a
limited release and the fourth highest
grossing british film ever at the time a
sequel called t2 train spotting and with
boyle in the main cast returning was
released in 2017 and is loosely based on
welsh's sequel book pornhub
schindler's list
[Music]
you're not buying them
[Music]
you're buying them you're
[Music]
finish the page and leave one space at
the bottom
[Music]
also among this group of the best book
adaptations ever is the 1993 film
schindler's list it was directed and
produced by steven spielberg and is
based on the 1982 nonfiction novel by
australian novelist thomas connealy
called schindler's arc the film tells
the story of oscar schindler a german
industrialist who as a member of the
nazi party ended up saving more than a
thousand mostly polish jewish refugees
from the holocaust by employing them in
his factories during world war ii
canoei's novel won a booker prize
literary award and the la times book
prize for fiction in 1983 and despite
him writing a number of well-received
books over the years the popularity of
this film adaptation has made this book
his signature work one of the survivors
named poldek pfefferberg had made it his
mission in life to tell the story of the
man who saved him and even tried
producing a biopic of schindler back in
1963 with mgm but couldn't get it off
the ground fast forward a couple decades
to connelly's book release in 82 which
would eventually garner the interest of
spielberg after studio exec sent him a
review of schindler's art
you have no idea
if i just there will be
because of what you did
i didn't do enough
you did so much
the director wasn't sure if he was ready
to make a holocaust film and tried
passing it along to other directors
before eventually deciding to do it
steven's alien wrote the screenplay and
spielberg shot the film in black and
white over a 90-day stretch in poland
approaching it as more of a documentary
than a feature in many ways the final
product is what many critics consider to
be one of the greatest films ever made
it earned 322 million dollars on a 22
million dollar budget that math is easy
and was nominated for 12 academy awards
winning seven including best picture
best director best original score and
you know it's coming best adapted
screenplay
little women i have been second to joe
my whole life in everything
and i will not be the person you settle
for just because you cannot have her
i won't i won't do it
i won't not when i've spent my entire
life loving you
next on this list is a film that has
made a big impact and that's 2019's
little women the film was written and
directed by greta gerwig and her second
solo directing effort after 2017's lady
bird and it marks the seventh film
adaptation of the 1868 novel of the same
name by louisa may alcott the ensemble
cast includes stars like circa ronan
emma watson florence pugh laura dern
timothy shalaby meryl streep and bob
odenkirk to name a few and it tells the
story of the march sisters as told
through the eyes and voice of joe march
played by ronin gerwig has said the book
inspired her to become a writer and
director and she urged her agent to get
in touch with the studio so she could be
considered and what do you know she got
the gig well giggs
you see gerwig started writing the
screenplay in early 2018 and found
inspiration in letters and diaries of
louisa may alcott along with 19th
century paintings of young women she
also used other stories from alcott to
shape the dialogues for this flick
do you love it
if he asked me again i think i would say
yes
do you think he'll ask me again
but do you love him
i care more to be loved
i want to be loved
that is not the same as loving
but and most likely what helped her land
the job was the slight addition gerwig
made to the script imagining that joe
march is actually the author of the
novel little women for this she received
plenty of praise for making a classic
feel fresh but still keeping its
essential elements gerwig also altered
the ending a little bit saying later
that she believed it quote honors
alcott's true vision given that she had
to satisfy the era's narrative
expectations end quote and that's a mic
drop
among the film's six oscar nominations
was best adapted screenplay for gerwig
along with best picture and taking home
one statue for best costume design and
when it comes to the adaptation the
consensus from critics says that with a
stellar cast and a smart sensitive
retelling of its classic source material
greta gerwig's little women proves some
stories truly are timeless to kill a
mockingbird in our courts
all men are
created
equal
i'm no idealist
to believe firmly in the integrity of
our courts and of our jury system
that's no ideal to me that is a living
working reality
next on this list is the 1962 drama to
kill a mockingbird the film is directed
by robert mulligan and comes from harper
lee's 1960 pulitzer prize-winning novel
of the same name
in the film it's gregory peck stepping
into the shoes of atticus finch a
widowed lawyer and father of two who was
assigned to defend a black man falsely
accused of raping a white woman the book
went on to become a classic of modern
american literature widely read in
middle and high school the story and
some characters are loosely based on
some of harper lee's observations of her
own surroundings while growing up in
monroeville alabama in the 30s and 40s
in adapting the novel writer horton
foote managed to follow the novel's slow
burn plot structure while also with the
help of the actors bringing the
characters to life speaking of which
when peck was offered the role of
atticus he quickly read lee's novel in
one sitting and immediately called
director robert mulligan to say that he
was in
luis stand up
[Applause]
your father's past
[Applause]
[Music]
peck took the role of atticus finch when
he was 45 and already oscar nominated
four times over but his performance
ended up becoming synonymous with the
character and with his career in general
even harper lee who based atticus on her
own father was so moved by peck's
performance that she gave him her
father's watch after filming was done
and of course he finally won his first
oscar for the role
the film itself was also a huge hit with
fans and critics earning more than six
times its budget at the box office and
with a total of eight academy award
nominations including best picture it
also won for best art direction and
dramatic pause best adapted screenplay
no country for old men
call it
colin yes
just call it
well
we need to know what we're calling it
for here you need to call it
i can't call it for you
it wouldn't be fair
i didn't put nothing out yes you did
you've been putting it up your whole
life you just didn't know it
and finally the last film on our list is
2007's no country for old men the film
is directed by joel and ethan cohen and
is based on the 2005 novel of the same
name by cormac mccarthy in what would
become a full circle moment mccarthy
originally wrote the story as a
screenplay before switching his focus to
a novel the title of which comes from
the first line of the 1926 wb8 poem
sailing to byzantium that is good for
your next trivia night the film follows
that mayhem did ensues after a hunter
played by josh brolin happens upon a
drug deal gone wrong and walks away with
more than 2 million dollars in cash from
the scene he is soon hunted himself by a
brutal killer played by javier bardem
and a sheriff played by tommy lee jones
no
i ain't gonna call it
that
the coin don't have no say
it's just you
i got here the same way the coin did
the film ended up being a huge critical
success nominated for eight oscars and
winning four including best picture best
director and best adapted screenplay for
the coen brothers plus javier bardem
became the first person to win the best
supporting actor at the sag bafta golden
globe critics choice and of course
academy awards
naturally the critics were also feeling
all of those feelings too over this
certified fresh film with a consensus
that says bolstered by powerful lead
performances from javier bardem josh
brolin and tommy lee jones no country
for old men finds the coen brothers
spinning cinematic gold out of cormac
mccarthy's grim darkly funny novel okay
there it is consider yourselves adapted
with the knowledge of the best book
adaptations ever i'm not sure i used
that word right but here we are
anyway this list could only have 10
films on it so we're assuming there's
others that you were thinking of like
jaws where was jaws so you all let us
know and now i leave you with the great
dilemma of the day to read the book or
watch the movie i think you know which
path i'm taking thanks for tuning in to
rt essentials i'm mark ellis
[Music]
[Music]
you